Sie sieht aus wie ein Mensch.
*verträumte Musik*
Sie liebt wie ein Mensch.
Sie kann weinen wie ein Mensch.
Und das,
obwohl sie eine Maschine ist.
Soji
ist ein empfindungsfähiger Android
aus der Star-Trek-Serie "Picard".
Sie zählt für mich
zum State of the Art
im Science-Fiction-Bereich.
Denn in der Serie
scheinen ihre Gefühle echt zu sein.
Aber was,
wenn sie nicht wirklich fühlt,
sondern menschliche Emotionen
einfach perfekt nachahmt?
Können Roboter so etwas schon?
Ist das überhaupt eine gute Idee?
Was denkst du?
- Das sollten wir checken.
Tag zusammen!
Jack Pop hier.
Star Trek war schon immer akkurat,
wenn es darum ging,
in die Zukunft zu blicken.
Touchscreens zum Beispiel
haben die vorhergedacht.
Aber auch Sprachsteuerung
oder Übersetzungs-Tools
à la Siri und Google Translate.
"Translation request being patched."
Aber wie sieht es aus
mit so menschenähnlichen Robotern,
also Androiden wie Soji?
Das kläre ich
mit der KI-Expertin Katharina Weitz.
Katharina forscht
an der Universität Augsburg daran,
die Interaktion zwischen KI
und Menschen zu verbessern.
3 Jahre lang war sie beteiligt
an der Entwicklung von VIVA,
einem sozialen Roboter, der auf
menschliche Gefühle reagieren kann.
An Star Trek catcht sie vor allem
der Blick in die Zukunft.
Katarina, schön, dass du da bist.
Lebe lang und in Frieden
Hast du das?
Schwierig.
Ich habe ewig gebraucht
und immer die falsche Hand genommen.
Immer rechts?
Dann habe ich das
intuitiv richtig gemacht.
Wir schauen gleich,
was VIVA oder andere Roboter
in Sachen Emotionen so drauf haben.
Vorher schauen wir uns das Beispiel
aus der Serie an.
Wer Soji ist und was sie kann,
erklärt uns Manniac vom Kanal Flipps.
Hi Jack.
Soji ist im Labor entstanden
und erst 3 Jahre alt,
als wir sie kennenlernen.
Ihr Vater bzw. das bauliche Vorbild
ist Data.
Ein Android, der früher unter Picard
in der Sternflotte gedient hat.
Allerdings ist Soji nicht mehr
zu unterscheiden von einem Menschen.
Nicht einmal sie selbst
weiß zu Beginn der Serie,
dass sie eine Maschine ist.
Das erfährt sie erst von Picard.
I know it must be very hard.
Everything you believed in ...
Your memories, your identity.
My dreams, my body, my parents,
my sister, all of us fake.
Der schiebt noch hinterher,
dass ihre Schwester getötet wurde.
Als Reaktion kullern die Tränen
wie beim echten Menschen.
I am so sorry.
Your sister is dead.
(Jack) Also
ein perfekter Maschinenmensch.
Lass uns bei dieser Szene bleiben,
weil die so hochemotional ist.
Wir nehmen sie auseinander.
Als erstes ist ja für den Roboter
und Androiden wichtig,
überhaupt erst mal
Emotionen zu erkennen.
Dafür nutzen wir Emotionstheorien
aus der Psychologie.
Zum Beispiel die Basisemotionen
von Paul Ekman.
Den kennen wir
aus unserer Glass-Onion-Folge.
Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere,
hat er für die Basisemotionen
wie Wut und Trauer
Gesichtsausdrücke definiert.
Genau, Action Units.
Das sind mimische Bewegungen
im Gesicht,
die Emotionen
zugeordnet werden können.
VIVA kann das bei mir erkennen?
- Ja, probier es mal aus.
Engage.
Okay, dann würde ich sagen,
VIVA, schau mal traurig.
Denk an die Aufrufzahlen
unter "Stirb langsam".
*traurige Musik*
VIVA erkennt jetzt, dass du
deine inneren Augenbrauen hebst,
dass du die Augenbrauen
zusammenziehst.
Und dass du die Mundwinkel
nach unten ziehst.
Mithilfe von Emotionsbildern
hat VIVA eben gelernt,
dass dieser Ausdruck
Trauer bedeutet.
Man kann das auch
für andere Emotionen machen.
Es gibt mittlerweile
viele Datensätze mit diesen Bildern.
Das passen wir dann
auf den Roboter an.
Klingt mega kompliziert,
aber funktioniert.
VIVA ist ganz gut
technisch ausgestattet.
Einmal mit der Kamera, die deinen
Gesichtsausdruck aufnimmt.
Und dann die Software, die KI,
das Emotionsmodell,
was deinen Gesichtsausdruck
interpretiert und klassifiziert.
Es ist natürlich sehr einfach,
wenn du so einen
prototypischen Trauerblick hast.
In der Wirklichkeit ist es oft so,
dass sich mit der Emotion Trauer
noch andere Emotionen vermischen.
Wie Angst oder Wut.
Oder dass eine Emotion
nicht so deutlich gezeigt wird.
Dann ist es schwieriger für VIVA,
die Emotion zu erkennen.
Das stimmt, man konzentriert sich ja
in so einer Situation nicht darauf:
Wie gucke ich gerade?
Um dir zu zeigen, wie schwierig
es auch für uns Menschen ist,
Emotionen zu erkennen,
habe ich Bilder mitgebracht
mit Emotionsausdrücken.
Du kannst jetzt raten,
ob die Person ein Tennismatch
gewonnen oder ob sie verloren hat.
Sehr gut, ein Quiz.
Ihr könnt auch mitmachen.
Es ist nicht gefakt, ich habe es
wirklich noch nicht gesehen.
Also gewonnen:
Fröhlichkeit, Freude.
Beim Verlieren:
Trauer und Enttäuschung?
Genau.
Let's go.
- Starten wir mal.
Das 1. Bild.
Das ist schwierig.
Das kann Schmerz sein.
Ich würde sagen:
gewonnen, große Freude.
Leider nein, verloren.
Verloren, schade.
Der ärgert sich.
Ich habe noch ein anderes.
*Jack lacht.*
Eine harte Nummer.
Verloren.
Gewonnen.
- Nein.
Und noch ein letztes.
Das ist verloren.
- Das ist eindeutig gewonnen.
Nein, niemand guckt so,
wenn er gewonnen hat.
Du siehst,
Emotionen zu kategorisieren
ist selbst für uns Menschen
ohne Kontext ziemlich schwierig.
Absolut.
Aber wir können festhalten, mit
einem Emotionsdatensatz und einer KI
ist es schon möglich,
dass Roboter das hinkriegen.
Wenn wir noch mal
in die Szene schauen,
sehen wir das auch dort,
aber es reicht nicht.
Wenn Soji die ganze Zeit
nur Picards Trauer erkennen würde,
aber dann nichts mehr passiert,
wäre es auch komisch.
Das heißt,
da muss jetzt noch mehr kommen?
Das würde auch gar nicht natürlich
oder menschlich wirken.
Der nächste Schritt
für den Roboter ist,
auf deine Emotion zu reagieren.
Wir können das
mit VIVA ausprobieren.
Am besten schaust du VIVA
traurig an
und wir lassen sie dann reagieren.
Okay.
Du siehst traurig aus.
Kann ich dir helfen?
Okay, funktioniert.
Funktioniert gut.
Jetzt hatten wir nicht nur
die Emotionserkennung,
sondern mithilfe der KI konnte VIVA
auf deine Emotionen reagieren.
Mit Trost.
- Fand ich gut.
Aber auch das passt nicht immer.
Die Emotionslage in der Picard-Szene
ist ja recht verzwickt.
Picard ist traurig,
er hat auch einen Grund dazu.
Aber bei Soji ist es so:
Durch den Verlust ihrer Schwester,
der deutlich schwerer wiegt,
müsste ihre Aufgabe nicht sein,
Picards Trauer zu erkennen
und ihn zu trösten.
Sondern erkennen:
Ich habe in dieser krassen Situation
den Trost verdient.
Das ist vielschichtig.
Das stelle ich mir tricky vor,
das einem Roboter beizubringen.
Das ist die große Herausforderung,
den Kontext zu erkennen.
Du hast es bei den Bildern gemerkt,
es ist schwierig, ohne Kontext
die Emotionen einzuschätzen.
Es geht also nicht nur darum,
dass VIVA deine Emotionen erkennt,
sondern auch um das Drumherum.
Was du sagst, aber auch kulturelle
Aspekte oder Erfahrungswerte.
Wir können das mal ausprobieren.
Lächle VIVA mal an
und erzähl eine traurige Geschichte.
Okay.
Ähm ...
VIVA ...
Gestern habe ich mir beim Basteln
den Holzbohrer
direkt unter den Fingernagel gejagt.
Das tat sauweh
und am Ende ist das ganze Baustück
kaputtgegangen.
Tolle Sache,
das freut mich für dich.
Schönen Dank auch.
*Lachen*
Wenn der Kontext eine Rolle spielt,
wird es für uns
und für VIVA schwierig,
das richtig zu interpretieren.
Das zeigt sich in einer Studie,
die wir gemacht haben.
Wir haben Bewerbungsgespräche
analysiert.
Und zwar haben dort Interviewer
unangemessene Fragen gestellt
z.B. zur Kleidung.
Das Ganze
wurde von den interviewten Personen
meistens mit einem Lächeln
aufgenommen.
Das war kein Zeichen der Freude,
sondern eher ein Schamgefühl.
Die Personen haben versucht,
ihre Emotionen zu regulieren und
sich das nicht anmerken zu lassen.
Da kommt die KI nicht mehr mit.
Genau wie bei VIVA
wird dann Freude klassifiziert,
obwohl es in der Situation
gar nicht passend wäre.
Das gleiche Problem
haben wir auch beim Thema Sarkasmus.
Das wird besonders tricky,
weil den kriegen nicht mal
alle Menschen auf die Reihe.
What kind of doctor
removes shoes from asses?
Depending on the depth
that's either proctologist
or a general surgeon.
*Das Publikum lacht.*
Wenn wir das im Star-Trek-Jargon
ausdrücken wollen,
sind wir wahrscheinlich
ein paar Serien zurück aktuell.
Und eher in unserer Data-Phase
als in einer Soji-Phase.
Ich denke, das kann man sagen.
Data sieht schon
menschenähnlich aus.
Das bekommt man
auch heute schon ganz gut hin.
Es gibt schon viele Beispiele dafür.
Was der KI noch nicht gut gelingt:
menschliches Verhalten und Emotionen
passend zum Kontext zu erkennen.
Das fällt auch Data noch schwer.
I'm attempting
to fill a silent moment
with nonrelevant conversation.
Small talk.
Yes, Sir.
I found that humans often use
small talk during awkward moments.
Therefore I've written
a new subroutine in for that purpose.
How did I do?
Ein bisschen Zeit haben wir ja noch.
In der Serie taucht Soji
erst im 24. Jahrhundert auf.
Okay, that's good.
We'll all just go and wait.
Aber die Frage ist:
Wollen wir das überhaupt?
In der Serie bringen Soji und Co.
einige Probleme mit sich.
Welche das sind,
erklärt uns Manniac.
Wie die meisten SciFi-Serien
kommt auch "Star Trek: Picard"
nicht ohne die Angst aus, dass
Roboter eine Gefahr werden könnten.
Weil sie
ihre eigenen Ziele verfolgen.
Soji und ihre Schwester werden
deshalb von Romulanern gejagt.
Weniger offensichtlich,
aber deutlich realer
sind die emotionalen Konflikte,
die Soji bei Picard auslöst.
Um sie zu retten,
bringt er in der 1. Staffel
reale Menschen in Gefahr.
Picard handelt wegen Soji
definitiv irrational.
Wie sehr er emotional involviert ist,
sehen wir, wenn er über Data spricht.
And you loved him.
I ...
Yes, in my way.
Hier redet er sogar von Liebe, obwohl
wir von einer Maschine sprechen.
Ja, da müssen wir nicht weit
in die Zukunft gucken.
Stell dir vor, ich schlage
mit einem Hammer VIVA kaputt.
Okay, das gefällt VIVA nicht.
Ich gebe zu, sie hat vorhin
meine Situation nicht ernstgenommen.
Aber ich würde dich
davon abhalten wollen.
Was denkt ihr?
Könntet ihr VIVA kaputtmachen
oder habt ihr VIVA liebgewonnen?
Schreibt mir das in die Kommentare.
Da reihst du dich ein
in viele Erkenntnisse von Studien.
Die Forscherin Kate Darling
hat gesagt,
wir sind noch lange nicht so weit,
emotionsfähige Roboter zu bauen.
Aber bereits jetzt empfinden
wir etwas für diese Roboter
und das ist das, was zählt.
Das zeigt sich auch
in Studien mit Robotern,
die wenig menschenähnlich sind.
Z.B. die Roboter-Robbe Paro
oder auch Staubsauger-Roboter.
Zu denen
bauen wir eine Beziehung auf
und haben Emotionen ihnen gegenüber.
Der Effekt verstärkt sich noch,
wenn die menschenähnlicher werden.
Nicht unbedingt.
Der japanische Forscher
Masahiro Mori hat 1970
den Begriff des "Uncanny Valley"
geprägt.
Er beschreibt damit,
dass sehr menschenähnliche Roboter,
Androiden, aber auch Handprothesen
von uns oft als nicht lebendig
wahrgenommen werden.
Denn sie imitieren noch nicht
perfekt das menschliche Verhalten.
Das führt dann dazu, dass wir uns
davor ziemlich gruseln.
The sky is clear.
Who the hell are you?
- Harby, Sir.
Are you feeling alright?
- No.
Das kippt hoffentlich in Zukunft,
wenn wir es schaffen, perfekt
menschenähnliche Roboter zu bauen.
Hm, bei Soji haben wir da
auf den 1. Blick keine Probleme.
Die wirkt absolut menschlich,
hat keine Probleme, das anzunehmen.
Was, wenn wir dieses Level
nicht erreichen?
Wir kommen nicht ins Soji-Level.
Sollten wir dann mit Absicht
weit drunter bleiben,
um nicht ins Uncanny Valley
zu kommen?
Um Grunde ja.
Das ist die These, die Forscher
Ben Shneiderman vertritt.
Er sagt, Roboter sind Roboter,
Menschen sind Menschen.
Wir sollten das nicht vermischen.
Wir sollten keine menschenähnlichen
Roboter erschaffen,
die Emotionen in uns hervorrufen.
Wenn du an deinen Laptop denkst,
den willst du auch nicht drücken.
Nicht unbedingt.
Wenn wir VIVA sehen,
machen wir es offensichtlich doch.
Warum entwickeln wir
menschenähnliche Roboter?
Das ist die andere Seite
der Wissenschaft.
Menschenähnliche Roboter
haben Vorteile.
Z.B. wenn wir sie
im sozialen Bereich einsetzen.
Etwa in Altersheimen.
Sie können Menschen unterstützen,
aktiver zu werden, Sport zu treiben
oder Demenzpatienten
oder -patientinnen assistieren.
Oder einfach zuhören.
Wir können uns auch andere
Einsatzmöglichkeiten vorstellen.
Als Haushaltshilfe
oder in Assistenzjobs.
Das wird schon
an der Uni Marburg ausprobiert.
Okay, also haben wir 2 Lager,
in der Wissenschaft wie auch bei uns.
Die einen sehen die großen Chancen,
die anderen sehen eher die Problem,
die sie mit sich bringen.
Was sagt ihr?
Seid ihr Team Robo-Mensch
oder Team Robo-Maschine?
Schreibt mir das in die Kommentare.
Vielen Dank, dass du da warst.
- Gerne.
Megaschöne Erklärungen.
Danke auch an VIVA
und v.a. danke an Manniac
vom Kanal Flipps.
Flippst doch mal rüber zu denen
und lasst Liebe da.
Vergesst aber bitte auf keinen Fall,
diesen Kanal zu:
Abonnieren
und die Glocke zu drücken.
Sonst gibt es Stress.
Das wollen wir nicht.
Also macht das.
Bis bald, tschüss.
Haben wir ein größeres Problem?
VIVA, hast du was damit zu tun?
*Quietschen.*
Ich mache jetzt das Licht hier.
Niemand weiß, was passiert.
Ich habe das Studio übernommen.
*Alle lachen.*
Das wird das Outtake für die Folge.
Ich weiß es.